de toute venteto FIFA 24
il y a plus de 10 ans le Qatar était en
liesse après l'annonce du président de
la FIFA Seb la terre dans une entrevue
au quotidien suisse TAG Allemagne celui
qui a régné durant 17 ans à la tête de
la toute-puissante fédération fait
maintenant marche arrière et déclare que
le Qatar est une erreur ajoutant que le
choix était mauvais
cette bombe lancée à quelques jours du
coup d'envoi n'est pas anodine l'ancien
président cherchant doute à se dédouaner
car depuis son attribution le petit pays
du Golfe a été dénoncé pour ses
pratiques d'une autre époque conditions
de travail inhumaine des milliers de
morts sur les chantiers de construction
des droits humains bafoués et des
enquêtes en cours sur une possible
corruption dans l'attribution de
l'événement sans oublier les problèmes
environnementaux
comme si cela n'était pas suffisant
Khalid Salman un ancien joueur de soccer
cathari qui est un des ambassadeurs pour
faire la promotion de l'événement a
déclaré à la chaîne allemande ZDF
l'homosexualité était un dommage mental
également chargé des sports Nancy fazer
de telles déclarations sont horribles à
tel déclarées
il y a quelques jours la FIFA a demandé
à toutes les nations participantes de se
concentrer sur le football et de ne plus
penser aux critiques quotidiennes contre
le Qatar la plupart ont fait abstraction
de cette demande d'ailleurs les
capitaines de certaines équipes ont
décidé de porter un brassard aux
couleurs arc-en-ciel durant la Coupe du
monde
ici Robert crozy Radio-Canada Montréal